let's dive down into the ocean in the
Cambrian period 520 million years ago
it's teeming with life down here these
are some of the most ancient animals
evolutionary experiments of all these
bizarre creatures it was this ferocious
predator that held Dominion it's from a
group called the animal occurrence but
now 520 million years on a fossil from
Greenland is adding a new dimension to
the story of these Cambrian monsters
the animal knock words they were quite a
diverse group of forms that we interpret
as being predators so they were swimming
through the water and capturing
relatively large prey that was in the
water or was sitting on the sea floor
but this new animal awkward that we've
discovered was quite different the
locality that we've been working on is
called serious passage which is situated
in north Greenland about eighty two
point five degrees north so you almost
at the North Pole and what that means is
that we have daylight all day long the
Sun is just moving around in a circle
out there serious passage is teeming
with fuzzles and also teeming with
fossils that we don't necessarily always
find in other localities and the
locality hasn't really been explored
that much previously so we knew that
we're going to find a lot of soft bodied
fossils and we also knew there was a
good chance that we're going to find
something completely novel we basically
just sit on the hillside and take chunks
of rock out every time you split the
rocks there are some remarkable soft
bodied fossils and then occasionally
you'll find something spectacularly new
and you don't really know what to expect
when I first discovered these animal
awkward appendages I didn't have any
expectations of that they were going to
be there and how they're going to look
like so it was quite something when you
split the rock and you see this big
appendage and you realize that it's
something that hasn't been seen ever
before
so this is the fossil that made us
realize that we had something remarkably
new because what we see is that they
have very very nice delicate spines of a
similar length going down the appendage
and what we also can see is that on
those fine spines there is a very very
regularly arranged set of bristles and
this is remarkably different from any
other animal awkward that we know of
because those forms they typically have
very short and stout spines which are
used for grasping a pinching prey this
thing would not have been able to do is
anything like that so we hadn't thought
about what on earth this particular
malakut might have been doing and we
realized that there was a lot of
similarities to suspension feeders forms
that are filtering particles out of the
water the way that they appendage is
arranged on the body we cannot really
envision that it was able to swim up
against the water current and thereby
have the filter paradis collecting
particles rather we think that they were
browsing through the border and then
using a technique that we have called
sweet net feeding where the basically
was sweeping the appendages through the
water and in the process of that they
would entrap particles in their feeding
appendage and then when they curl up the
appendage they would actually move it up
adjacent to the mouth and then the mouth
could have sucked in these particles
today sharks and whales have taken the
animal or its crown as the most fearsome
predators in the ocean but some of these
predators too have evolved into large
suspension feeders gentle giants in fact
it's happened a handful of times in
Earth's history as yet
researchers aren't sure why some apex
predators hang up their fangs and become
gentle giants
as we were describing this thing and we
were making these comparisons to largely
toning suspension feeders elsewhere in
earth history there was an entry that
was made for a speculative art book and
one of the entries were an artist from
Connecticut who was speculating upon the
fact that perhaps the animal awkward's
could become large neutronic suspension
feeders as well he named this
hypothetical clade of filter-feeding
animal awkward's the city carrots the
whale shrimps and we thought that in
order to honor the fact that he actually
hypothesized on the existence of this
group that we would name this group of
filter-feeding animal awkward's the city
carrots as well
you